you
what's going on guys welcome back to the
swing index tutorial video in the last
video we calculated our and now we need
to continue on and do the next
calculation which is actually k so to
calculate K it's a lot easier than our
was k is just the largest of either h2
minus e1 or l2 minus e1 so that is easy
enough so now we're going to go ahead
and make a function for define calc
underscore k and within here all we need
are the variables of h 2 l/2 in c 1
colon and x equals H two minus c1 and y
equals L 2 minus C 1 if x is greater
than Y then k equals x we'll go ahead
and just print k and will return k L if
X is less than Y K equals y and actually
we could even just say else k equals y
in fact I'll just go ahead well leave it
there just so it's clear but that would
probably be the most efficient to just
say else but whatever print k and return
okay now that will actually calculate
Kate let's go ahead and run the
calculation okay just to be sure so k
equals 0 calc k and again we need H to
l2 and see one so high to low to close
one and we'll just print k so we'll run
this and now we see that the k is equal
to two point eight so we have our value
for K since we were able to type that
out pretty quick let's go ahead and
start the calculation for the entire
swinging index now
so now we're going to say L well we
already know I was equal to the limit
move so in our little variable here way
up here we just recalled limit move that
so l equals LM or actually let's just
call it will call it limit move for now
now I changed my mind here's what we're
going to do we're going to say l equals
LM and then what we need to do now that
we've done all this is run to the very
top of this script and right above
defined Kalkar we're going to define the
parent function as define swing index
and the parameters for swinging x 0 1 0
to h 1 h 2 l 1 l 2 c1 c2 LM those are
the parameters then highlight everything
we've done thus far besides the
printouts down here and hit and actually
I guess they could stay so we'll
highlight everything and hopefully that
doesn't happen to you that was none try
again hit tab and that I'll tab them all
over so now we've got the definitions of
L R and K very clearly here and also now
that we've done this we can actually
change this to H to c 1 l 2 0 1 75 to LM
this to h2 this to l2 and this to see
one that's like storming outside my
lights just went out look like and
finish this anyway us we've done that
now we need to go ahead and fill in all
the values for this so we can actually
run the parent function and continue on
with the tutorial so paste here and now
we have to do all the replacers here
open one open to buy one
high-to-low one low too close one close
to in limit move is an actually sense
we've defined limit up here we'll just
copy and paste that variable right down
here long function there now just to
make sure that we've plugged everything
in the way it ought to be now let's go
ahead and run this one more time and
make sure this if these prints some
stuff out without printing out an error
for us ok cool so it did it printed
everything out it's still the same
variable so that's a good sign right now
so the next thing that we want to do now
is actually set up the final calculation
of the swing index so I'm going to
conclude the video here in the next
video we will complete our swing index
function a lot of code for this little
swing index so anyway stay tuned to the
next video as always thanks for watching
things for the support the subscriptions
and until next time